hi I'm Meg and I Milenka we are Cornell
University students from the mineral
nutrition course and we're here to tell
you about copper nutrition and people
and plants copper is a transition metal
and one of the elements in the periodic
table all life on Earth needs copper to
survive including us humans we use
copper as a cofactor and many proteins
called Cooper enzymes or copper atoms
sub polypeptide chains of amino acids
reactive for other metals in our bodies
like iron copper and it's proteins have
important roles throughout our bodies
including brain function immune function
and red blood cell production his copper
is such an important nutrient there are
severe health effects if we are
deficient in it
children born without sufficient copper
during their mother's pregnancies have
issues with bone formation and with
their cardiovascular systems they also
can have abnormalities with brain and
immune system function for the rest of
their lives adults with copper
deficiency meanwhile have cardiovascular
problems including those concerning
cholesterol blood sugar and regular
heartbeats and they can have
neurological and behavioral problems as
well that doesn't mean we can't have too
much copper however the metal is toxic
at high levels because it can make
reactive oxygen species from oxygen
molecules that can tear apart cells
especially the mitochondria the
powerhouses of the cell luckily most
people's bodies do a good job of
controlling them out of copper in
ourselves so this is not usually an
issue but our bodies can't control is
how much copper we have access to like
all essential nutrients we have to each
regular supply of copper to stay alive
one of the main sources from which
humans acquire nutrients is plants who
in turn take up nutrients from the soil
planets like all other living things be
copper and it's important for the growth
development and fertility of plants it
plays an important role in
photosynthesis reactive oxygen species
detoxification hormone perception and
cell wall formation while humans are
free to make changes in their diet
plants are restricted by the environment
that growing and the availability of
nutrients in the soil almost 30% of
farmland across the globe is made of
neutral or basic pH soils that are
considered to be copper deficient signs
and a plant has copper deficiency
include a slow growth rate the yellowing
of young leaves and inability to form
wood a lack of flowers and few seeds
meaning plans like wheat and rice might
not produce enough grains for farmers
however just like in humans copper can
also be toxic if it is accumulated in
excess symptoms of toxicity are
yellowing of mature leaves slow root
growth in the production of reactive
oxygen species in order to keep the
copper levels at the range that are best
for them plants tightly regulate all the
processes that take up and redistribute
copper uptake of copper into plants is
done by copper transporter proteins some
of these are in the CDR Copts family and
are important for taking up copper from
the soil into the roots since pre copper
is not a safe form to keep in living
cells it has to be bound to molecules
called ligands or chaperones once in the
plant copper needs to be taken from the
root cells to the xylem where it can be
carried throughout the plant loading
copper into the xylem cells requires a
transporter protein from the HMA family
after moving through the xylem copper it
slivered 2 leaves flowers and fruit by
the YSL and CTR compt transporters all
these proteins are regulated by
different proteins called transcription
factors determine which other genes in
the plant's DNA can be transcribed and
translated
letters into proteins the main
transcription factors that control
copper levels are SPL 7 and C igf-1 they
regulate all of the transporters we
describe to make sure enough copper is
taken up however the amounts of copper
in soil are not high enough another
strategy can be activated it is called
copper economy mode and at Redis tribute
copper from left needed areas and
processes towards the most important
ones such as photosynthesis in the lead
there is a lot that goes into
controlling copper in plants whether
taking it up in soil or carrying it from
one part of the plant to another but we
hope you have convinced you why it is
important unless you're a big fan of
eating liver bones are you most of your
copper comes from plants like wheat or
corn and that copper is critical for so
many parts of your own body healthy
plans to feed healthy people we hope you
have enjoyed this video
[Music]